after seven years Tunisia remains the
one Arab country to emerge from the
so-called Arab Spring as a functioning
democracy or does it my guest here at
the Munich Security Conference is
chemist Janelle we the country's foreign
minister has the shine finally come off
the revolution and with it the hope of a
better future
[Music]
imogen ah welcome to complex on thank
you very much for having me you told a
newspaper in India last November that
Tunisia was now as secure as any country
in the world not true is it when I think
compared to 2015 and 16 I can repeat the
same statement that they as secure as
any country in the world there are five
areas listed as no-go areas by the State
Department US State Department no but I
mean when I said this because I compared
with 2015 when we had the first
terrorist attacks attack and then on the
9 2016 today I think that our forces are
better trained well equipped but not as
secure as any country in the world err
well as most of the countries really yes
when you read what the State Department
has to say give you an example western
mountains and champion National Park
terrorist groups continue to operate in
the mountains of western Tunisia gen
dooba ok Kasserine near the Algerian
border terrorist groups continue to
operate in these areas sidi bouzid in
central tunisia terrorist groups
continue to operate in this area that
doesn't sound very exaggerated frankly
these are the department doesn't know
what let me tell you these are the
fringes I mean on the border of Tunisia
these are you are talking about
mountains and these mountains of course
we never said that talk about territory
in Tunisia yeah but these are these are
very small groups they are very well
tackled by our forces we know them where
they are moving and we are following
them but I put it to you that your
advice is dangerously misleading you
should people believe the State
Department with the biggest most
sophisticated intelligence service in
the world or the Ministry of a country
who wants to revive its tourists in but
this is not saying that we need is not
secure I just the same places not to go
p.m. not to go there also you have
places where you're not to go there are
threats all over the world yes but
they're not no good
there is no territory in Tunisia held by
terrorists there is no what they said no
terrorist groups continue to operate in
this area three three four five areas
yes we say it but they are not holding
territories they are few groups they are
acting
we are following them but we have been
this threat we are aware of it but they
are not holding yeah we are not in like
other Middle Eastern countries where the
terrorists were able to hold the
territories Tunisia is completely under
control of the state mr. Gianelli your
own interior minister gave a vivid
picture of the hugely extensive
terrorists operating in your country he
said in 2017 he broken up forty networks
sending terrorists to conflict zones six
armed terror networks more than a
hundred and twenty terrorist recruiting
cells how many hundreds of others are
there that you don't know about that you
haven't got this is a huge expensive
network of terrorists operating in your
code yes but these are these are Saints
these these shows first of all that our
forces now they know about these cells
we were working these cells they don't
know about the next one yeah but they
know that but but let's be very happy
that to tell you that the last two years
Tunisia was immune of any terrorist
threat this is to the benefit of our
security forces you have several
thousand Tunisians who went off to fight
with Isis and reputed to be the largest
per capita number from any country some
of them have been filtering back home we
don't know how good your border controls
are in 2015
a report by Transparency International
said your security and customs officials
suffered from a lack of transparency and
scrutiny so we don't know how good your
border controls are these people coming
back in first it won't be complacent
Africa speaking first of all speaking
about seven thousands I think here you
are exaggerating these are reports by
the media these are reports they said
several several thousands I didn't say
seven I said several
several thousands nobody is able to
count them to say that there are trees
these are people working I mean fighting
in the hotspots nobody I was coming and
their cell and you have no property
radicalization program in your country
no property radicalization program
according to the tunisian forum for
economic and social rights there's
there's no problem there is no problem
of what the radicalization of course
there is of course there is a
comprehensive policy regarding health
trying to derail a decay lies all these
young people it's what they're telling
you on behalf of the government that
there is a national comprehensive
program tackling with working with women
within education in Social Affairs and
the it's a warrant or the Department of
there may be but a lot of these people
who come back is sitting under house
arrest
don't they of course it becomes Salatin
that's not de radicalization now if i
may come in any in any democratic we're
a country well which is respecting the
role of law these people when they come
back of course they are held enter
abated by the police and if found guilty
they go to the court and of course they
will be prosecuted accordingly let's
talk about your claim to be respecting
law because your government's commitment
to human rights and democracy has also
been contested the International Crisis
Group warned last month that Tunisia was
drifting back towards its old
authoritarian reflexes something I'm
sure you'll deny but Freedom House
reported that your failure to
consolidate democracy meant a sharp
decline in this year's Freedom Index
reflecting it said a pattern of
authoritarian behavior and the president
sepp see but the Freedom House rated
Tunisia the first in the Arab and MENA
region Freedom House Tunisia is the most
free country in that part it's not
living up to the hopes it says with the
latest downgrade they've downgraded it
is number one no they downgrade
but they have done great latest
downgrade Tunisia has come dangerously
close to losing its status as the only
free/busy to emerge from these kind of
reports this is not reported by
everybody these are frankly speaking I
don't know on which most of the human
rights organizations Western human
rights organizations they do not have a
good picture and I want to go into some
of these they do not have a good picture
of your progress towards the Democratic
swell let me tell you what we are doing
in the project I will explain to you
that we are but I just want to make the
point that it didn't inspire confidence
last September that three of the new
faces in the government had served as
ministers during the dictatorship of
penology and if they are able and
capable to do to handle their
departments I mean that that does not
mean they have not prosecuted by the by
the Justice they were never said that
these people do you know they committed
any crime that the old system what
signal is that what depends what depends
this is a revolution for if you're gonna
bring back all these old faces yes or
treaters but these people didn't serve I
mean dictator yeah but they were not
implicated you know involved in any
criminal --'tis there is no reason not
to frankly speaking in a democratic in a
system there is no reason to recruit
able people to run the country when the
run the country is going through
transition so we are generally did you
really imagine the Tunisian staged a
revolution in order to see these old and
discredited faces brought back according
to the Carnegie Endowment Bensalem
Patton Bensalem was widely seen as an
apologist of the old regime for denying
its human rights violations also
controversial your finance minister
research algún who was named in a
Carnegie Endowment posting as being
close to the Ben Ali family are these
really the people you want there well
frankly I don't know there are many
people but these people well there is no
signal we didn't choose them because
they belong
the old regime I mean the chief of
government the Prime Minister chose them
because he thought that these people are
the right fit for the this time Turin
there these Department of Education and
they're financed you want to collect you
want to correct the evils of the past
and you bring back with the people who
were directly associated with but these
people they were not involved in
security they didn't corrupt any people
or they were not involved in touches
these people are serving a civil servant
the ministers they were ministers yes
yeah but these two people they were
running technical departments they they
were not related to politics
last month Tunisia saw widespread social
protests in January there was widespread
concern among Western human rights
groups at the way your government
handled them even the UN's High
Commissioners right yes
the UN's High Commissioner for Human
Rights particularly exercised by the
many hundreds of people you arrested and
felt the need to remind you that all
those detained should have full respect
for their rights those concerns were
justified well let me first tell you the
protest in the democracy it's a healthy
sign the our functions learning about
the way wages handle yes time to protest
let me tell you openly and directly that
our forces handed these protests with a
lot of professionalism there was no
single casualties these there were
rioters there are looters but no single
casualties if in any democracy in in the
world it can happen some some accident
but here in tsunami these weren't
accidents on January the 31st Human
Rights Watch accused your police at
beating up some of the people detained
and denying their right to a lawyer
under tunisian law that's a direct
violation of your own laws and no i'm
not aware of these frankly speaking I
don't agree the Tunisian League of Human
Rights
yes visited 23 suspects yes in the
mornig year prison on January the 17th
they reported that most of them had
marks consistent with beatings on their
bodies persistent allegations of
mistreatment his mistreatment of policy
a deliberate policy introduced today I
can tell you know if there are sorry
maybe they're out of control but if
there are incident I can't I can't say
what had percent that didn't happen but
this is not what they can affirm to you
today but this is not a deliberate state
policy to get back pretty careless then
if it isn't a state policy because it's
going on a very young and witnesses were
interviewed and and victims were
interviewed as well according to Human
Rights Watch some people were arrested
simply for distributing leaflets that
the government didn't like calling for
so there is yes they arrested six handed
people seven hundred more than seven
more than seven hundred these people
most all of them they have been freed
those who were involved in looting
vandalism they went to the court okay
and they have been persecuted according
to the law Tunisia today is a country
which respects the role the rule of law
to call them all criminals and looters
it's the same kind of language that the
old regime all of them know frankly
speaking I don't say that all of them
some of these people are expressing real
social disparity of I understand and
they are in the right way yeah because
not my government's in the last seven
years have failed to meet their
expectations hasn't a nine government
but mr. Sebastian tell me let me tell
you this we are living in the transition
and in any transition period of course
you have stability of the government the
this is this but the question is which
there now is the transition going
forwards or backwards it is I would
suggest that there is national consensus
not to just the government including the
opposition that the democracy will to
consolidate the transition and the
democratic transition in Tunisia and
there is no going back
there is no returning and there is no
there is strong
will to continue on the path of
consolidating the democratic process
which is part of that during last year's
Universal Periodic Review at the Union
Human Rights Council your country came
under sustained criticism for aspects of
its behavior Amnesty International as
well as many other groups voiced concern
about impunity for torture and pointed
out there had actually been few if any
successful prosecutions of your
officials for torture that's a
disgraceful record first of all let me
these cases they are in the court and if
they are in the court today in Tunisia
we are working to have an independent
justice so it's up to the justice courts
to decide above the street not in the
the Special Rapporteur on the promotion
of truth justice and reparations said
last year many alleged perpetrators of
gross human rights violations remained
active in your security services how can
that be
could we say agree so the Special
Rapporteur on the promotion of truth
justice and reparation is Italy's Ian
he's a UN Special Rapporteur so he
reported at your Universal Periodic
Review session last year at the UN Human
Rights Council saying that the we
continued saying that many alleged
perpetrators are still employed and
active in your security services so you
don't even suspend them well well I
think most of them they have been
suspended they don't say that one half
percent now there is no people suspected
to be maybe involved in these kind of
practices but the most powerful what
what are the penalties for torture in
your country it's such torture is
forbidden by your an example of the
visibility's in in two cases in july
2015 where officials were found guilty
they received suspended sentence but
that's not that's not a deterrent yes
but that's not the committing torture
yes but there's a lot of presiding over
a country that doesn't deal with basic
justice yeah but this is the
of Justice is not matter you are talking
to executive Minister and are you proud
of this I'm not of course I am not so
what's gonna live in what is happening
if we I am sure my people and our people
they are looking to these shortcomings
and they are trying their best to
address them the Amnesty International
put it since 2011 the overwhelming
majority of credible allegations of
torture and other serious violations by
security forces have not been
independently and impartially
investigated is that the sort of country
that you want to preside making the
stuff most lost most most of the
Tunisian people most of the political
families in Tunisia this is not the case
the kind of country they want they
wanted a full fledged democratic country
we are proud of the achievements we have
already made we we are not yet a
democracy to be honest we are not yet to
democracy we never pretended that we are
full we finished achieve may promises we
are on the path of reaching a democratic
system where transparency the rule of
law where hand % will be respected you
told the Human Rights Council your
government last year in response to
their many criticisms that you would
ensure all allegations of torture are
impartially investigated when let me
when you're going to deliver I reiterate
that commitment if the government if my
my people you know said to the in Geneva
this that shows that of course they are
doing but but when how frankly you are
asking me question detail the question
which if you knew that you are going to
ask me this I would have brought you the
details but you know Human Rights
Minister Mac T Bhangarh BIA told Amnesty
International last year it was taking
time he said taking time to overcome the
Ben Ali legacy my question to you why is
it taking time if you tell your police
not to torture people anymore why is it
taking time for them to obey the order
well first of all we have to educate our
police we have to train them
yes but you don't torture PD yes yes but
no it is not a matter of torture it's a
matter of working and serving a
democratic system
this is murder they're out of control
you're saying you can't control I mean I
don't say that they are out of control
but I mean this is not the mainstream of
the Tunisian police what you are
depicted here is a wrong picture the
mainstream is trying to respect the rule
of law to respect a democratic system
but maybe in these there are some cases
and I never pretended that this is over
it's going to take time but there is
political will strong will to work
towards having a full-fledged democracy
where the respect of human rights and
the rule of law will be the rule of the
government mr. Jinnah what makes your
promise so difficult to believe is that
you are pressing ahead with a new law
that would actually extend the impunity
of your security services this is the
repression of attacks against the Armed
Forces bill this bill that is in
committee stage at the moment human
rights groups say if your promises to
the Human Rights Committee were genuine
you'd scrap this well it extends
impunity it allows the security services
to get away bill is not yet violations
this bill is not yet adopted it is under
discussion it has been controversial
that means that the government and those
who present that bill are listening to
the people and I am sure they will be
reaffirming it according to the will of
the people
you're sure about that well I said so
why I assure you that there are two very
controversial aspects in this law in
your interior minister said the other
way this law was going to go through it
wouldn't be withdrawn they're not going
to withdraw criminalizing so-called
denigration of police and other security
services and and the law about secrets
the proposal that anyone who discloses
or publishes national security related
secrets could spend ten years in jail
well well the the the idea is that low
it's now and the discussion and if there
are any reforms
and mentos that low they will be taken
care of and they will be met accordingly
there's a huge protest it's caused huge
protests from civil society in Tunisia
there are pressure from the police do
you think that you understand now today
Tunisia is a free country so there are
pressure from the police those police
forces who would like to get more like
to get away with any violation they want
to practice that's the truth isn't it
yeah and this law if it goes through as
it is written or not get as it is as I
said it's under discussion and I am sure
all these observation will be taken care
of when the law would be adopted
you're already and it it is under
discussion by the Parliament and there
are in the parliament ten political
parties so so the government which is
running this your Parliament you're
already under attack for the law that
you have passed which is the so-called
administrative reconciliation law let's
be clear it grants amnesty to civil
servants who facilitated corruption
under the Ben Ali regime without putting
them through any legal process what so I
let me explain to you this this is
getting away with everything
no no this is not good thing we've
passed this year this is already done so
let me explain to you this law because
you are getting a wrong information but
that law this is a law regarding those
civil servant who are working under
banana you who got the instruction the
political instruction to you no reason
of responsibility because they were
ordered to do something bad what are you
saying that they had no personal
responsibility no thank you the
difference no right and wrong know
whether they were instructor you see
what happens now
in the administration which is quite an
important tool for guaranteeing you know
the success of the transition in the
administration today nobody is able and
ready to sign anything he wants to get
you know protection the Lord directly
contradicts what the prime minister said
when he came to power in 2016 he said
our slogan today is
immunity for corruption to anyone but no
to hiding behind political cover which
is what they do
corruption crimes will not pass and then
you pass this Lobby which allows these
people didn't get money in their pocket
they didn't corrupt anybody they just
you know the they were in the lower
hierarchy they just implemented decision
so this law has been utterly rejected by
the International Center for
transitional justice as well as your own
National Council of the Bar Association
so popular is it that chose you although
there is a debate going on in Tunisia
ask you like the laws may pass yeah but
the law I mean we thought that this is a
way to help the administration running
the daily business of the government is
the way to help people escape their
responsibilities
their part in the dictatorship if we
have committed any crime this law does
not protect them them from being
prosecuted for any crime or corruption
because this is just related to the
civil civil part of their job you have
to read the law it has nothing to do I
mean if you are being Bar Association
read the law and they came up with a
completely different yeah because when
these who's looking after justice them
or you know they you know they bar and
the justice is not us we are looking at
there we are the executive branch and we
are not involved with the justice you
keep passing these laws which are so
unpopular you want the the west and the
IMF to continue funding these
anti-democratic processes it's not
democratic according to the
international justice some of our
lawyers not all of them some of they
contest this road they are in the right
to contains it but that doesn't mean
that they are right we are in the
democracy people are waiting for
milestones they are waiting for the
much-delayed Constitutional Court yes
which was promised they're waiting for
municipal elections H have delayed an
delay we see a prime minister who
promises that this will be the last
difficult year for the people of Tunisia
yes he's in no position to make a
promise like
why not well well let me first regarding
the Constitutional Court it will be
there before the end of 2018 that there
was the Prime Minister pledges the
promise this and it is ended now there
is a proposal in front of the parliament
it is like yeah but this is we are this
is before the the end of the mandate of
the government of this government deal
the municipal election will be taking
place on the 6th of May and just the
prime minister said that that date will
be respected and the election will will
take will take place that's the promise
is it it is not probably the commitment
all right mr. Qi now it's been good to
have you on the program thank you very
much for telling us thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]